demi lovato who recently declared that
she is a they
not because she has split into multiple
personalities or into multiple people
but because
she says that she is gender non-binary
despite the fact that she is a
biological female a person who is a
biological female um she has some words
about the labels that we use
for aliens
not
illegal aliens
aliens
so here is what she said quote i really
think that if there was anything out
there that would want to do that to us
it would have happened by now but i
think we have to stop calling them
aliens because aliens is derogatory term
for anything
that's why i like to call them ets so
yeah that's a little tidbit a little
information that i learned
it's true
she was visited by an alien and the
alien told her how insulted the alien
was
at her incorrect use of labels
because when they get off their
spaceship if they find out that we use
the word i mean they speak english
number one and number two they're very
woke so if they get off their spaceships
and they say how dare you use the word
aliens to refer to us as though we're
not domestic as though we're from
somewhere else as though you're
suggesting that we're not like born here
or that we don't belong here in some way
when they come out i'm just telling you
you're all laughing right now and you're
thinking yourself wow demi lovato seems
like kind of crazy that's what you're
thinking to yourself but when demi
lovato is made
the the ruler of earth by the alien
overlords
and they
are issuing commands
on behalf of the non-aliens the et's
ah your laughter will come to a
screeching halt there will be no more
laughter only tears for those of you who
are intolerant enough to call
extraterrestrials aliens
and i say i don't know like what
why why is what she's saying stupid
considering that everything else is so
unbelievably stupid like i've lost i'm
losing all capacity to adjudicate
gradations of stupid
because i'm not sure what's more stupid
about that than putting a gay man on the
cover of playboy honestly
i really i really am or or for that
matter getting rid of gender specific
toy sections and clothing sections and
stores yeah i'm
there are no more gradations of stupid
they've merged into a giant stupid blob
of stupid
there's no all the gradations are gone i
cannot rank the stupid anymore it is
just one vast pile of stupid
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content